[Music]
even when you die
[Applause]
or the prayer still hounded you all the
papers had to say
was that maryland was found in the news
and it seems to me you lived your
life like a candle in the wind
never knowing who to cling to
when the rain
[Music]
long before
[Music]
yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but i was just here
[Music]
legendary
[Music]
i pray you'll
[Music]
still be wise
in times when we don't know
[Music]
let this
[Music]
lead us to
[Music]
to place
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
let this
[Music]
peace
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
big
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
just like every child
just like every child
we need to find a place
give us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
day light say that you
want a sun
[Music]
is
[Music]
i am waiting
[Music]
for the day
now old deuteronomy just before dawn
through a silence you feel you could cut
with a knife
announces the cat who can now be reborn
and come back to a different
jellicle life
[Music]
foreign
memory turn your face
to the moonlight
let your never really do
[Music]
the meaning of what happened
[Music]
memory
[Music]
i was beautiful then
[Music]
i remember a time i knew what
happiness was
again
[Music]
a street lamb dies on another night
daylight
i must wait for the sunrise
i must think of a new life
and i mustn't give you
[Music]
when the dawn
[Music]
a comes day
[Music]
[Music]
the trees
[Music]
as the is breaking
the memory
[Music]
is
[Music]
of my days
if you touch me
you'll understand what happiness
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic and gin
he says son can you blame me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
[Music]
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
it says be i believe this is killing me
as a smile ran away from his face
well i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this place
[Music]
now paul is a real estate novelist
who never had time for a wife
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be for life
[Music]
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a dream they call
loneliness
but it's better than drinking alone
[Music]
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life for a while
it sounds like a carnivore and the
microphone smells like
a beer and they sit at the bar
and put bread in my jar and say man what
are you doing here
[Music]
you're a piano man
[Music]
and you've got us feeling alright
[Music]
what i call the basket of deplorables
though chumps out there with a
microphone
anyone who supports this is supporting
[Music]
racism
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this moment
[Music]
hold up hold up
[Music]
[Music]
but i don't know who i am
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how could
[Music]
i
know
[Music]
[Music]
some me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
bye
[Music]
hey baby come on
now it's time to leave
[Music]
but it ain't
[Music]
i just wanna tell you that i had enough
crazy but it ain't
[Music]
so give me one good reason
baby come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no more
[Music]
[Music]
i just want to tell you
but it ain't
[Music]
i know for sure
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our
[Music]
is
[Music]
my
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
times
[Music]
when are you gonna come down
when i
[Music]
[Music]
forever i didn't sign up with you
i'm not a present for your friends to
open those boys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
who
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my toes oh
[Music]
[Applause]
beyonce
[Music]
ow
[Music]
[Music]
but he can't win thanks for losing his
pride
what makes him mad he wasn't gonna
fail but he came in
he thinks mine and jail said
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
woman
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nope
[Music]
[Music]
right beside
[Music]
huh
[Music]
movement
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i see them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is on the grass
remembering frames and basic chains
[Music]
is
[Music]
the suburbs today are not the suburbs of
half a century
the suburbs are far more diverse than
the cities
but they're being targeted being
targeted for what
federalized centralized government
controlled
by the left democrats want to abolish
the suburbs they are too clean and nice
and therefore by definition
they are racist the biden campaign has
highly specific plans
on how to do this it's called
affirmatively furthering fair housing
it's a hud regulation
it was written during the obama
administration biden's advisers plan to
enforce it
towns will be ordered to abolish zoning
for single-family housing
because single-family homes needless to
say are racist
low-income federally subsidized
apartments will go up in the suburbs
we'll also build 1.5 million new energy
efficient homes
and public housing units
thankfully trump repealed this rule back
in july
but now the left is backing an even more
radical plan
it was a bill put forward by senator
cory booker to push
low-income housing developments into the
suburbs
this would be a federal takeover of
local zoning laws in essence
and biden he fully supports it
the prior administration piled up more
than 600
major new regulations a cruel and
punishing regulatory burden that cost
the
average american an additional two
thousand
three hundred dollars per year think of
that the average american
two thousand three hundred dollars
regulation
hitting low-income americans by far the
hardest
our historic regulatory relief is
providing the average american household
an extra
three thousand one hundred dollars every
single year
i've had the luxury of enjoying the
benefit of the tax cuts
the tax cuts allowed me to grow my
businesses i believe that if you
take into account the trump tax cut
you take into account the drop in
unemployment and particularly
unemployment for african americans the
lowest it's ever been in history
how's the economy right now we're loving
it kennedy credits the trump tax cuts
and deregulation for her company's
growth it's the first time
in 10 years that it's booming again the
tax cuts
that were imposed did wonders for
the the middle class i will cut taxes
even further
for hardworking moms and dads i will not
raise taxes i will cut them
first thing i do is going to repeal this
trump tax cut
do you believe there is systemic racism
in law enforcement
absolutely i've been a police officer
for nearly 32 years
joe biden does not have the backs of
police officers
joe biden's staffers they gave money to
a fund
to help bail out accused criminals joe
biden's silence is encouraging
the rioters kamala harris was working to
help the instigators the criminals get
out of jail
if joe biden's elected it's just going
to continue everyone beware
because they're not going to stop
the only person who defended the police
is trump i have had overwhelming support
from police my whole career
up until this year we can reduce the
responsibilities assigned to the police
and redirect some of the funding for
police do we agree that we can redirect
some of the funding
yes absolutely in joe biden's america
we'll all be in danger
if you support the police and you want
to be safe in your home and you want
your children safe
support donald trump
[Music]
oh
[Music]
are you listening to me
[Music]
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you can hang out with all the boys
[Music]
it's a place
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pick yourself up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my problem is i voted for nafta i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters trade
agreements like nafta and permanent
normal trade relations with china which
forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160 000
jobs the president is
absolutely right when he says that china
has been cheating for 25 years
and that bill clinton didn't do enough
about it george w bush didn't do enough
about it barack obama didn't do enough
about it
rising china is an incredibly positive
development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
development
it is in our self-interest that china
continue to prosper
we want to see china rise china is a
great nation
and we should hope for the continued
expansion china is not our enemy
we talk about china as our competitor
we should be helping the idea that china
is going to eat our lunch
it's bizarre
they're not bad folks folks china's not
a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which he supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us no do you think
in retrospect that you were naive about
china no
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the u.s mta is better
than nafta
it is better than nafta
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate
so vote vote visit iowa.com
ohio god bless you
uh can somebody tell joe by the way it's
not a real website and joe you're
running for president
not senator and by the way that senator
the mormon guy
is mitt romney not some mormon governor
now sadly what we showed you that's just
from a couple of hours today
because every time that joe actually
leaves the basement bunker
and stays out past 10 a.m well disaster
ensues
here's a quick reminder
tomorrow's superstar tuesday and i want
to thank you all
i tell you what i'm rushing ahead aren't
i we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women created by the go you
know the you know the thing
you agree with me go to joe 303
30. we choose truth over facts
play the radio make sure the television
excuse me
make sure you have the record player on
at night the the phone
make sure the kids hear words poor kids
are just as bright and just as tall as
white kids
donald trump does pose an excellent
strength to this
it's not hypothetical this is pretty
serious
by the way these are way beyond an
occasional campaign gap
and i am beginning well i'm more than a
little worried that this man
could represent a clear and present
danger to this country
he's obviously not capable of leading
he's been hiding the entire campaign
and the corrupt media mob is covering
for him
joe wants to be the president of the
united states of america
that would be the toughest job in the
world and at times
joe doesn't seem to remember that he's
even running for president
or what state he's in or what day of the
week it is does anyone
really believe that if elected that joe
biden will actually be
in control of anything what kind of
country we're going to be
four more years of george georgia he
uh gonna find ourselves in a position
where if uh
trump gets elected uh we're gonna be uh
we're gonna be in a different world
brock and i think it's a rape for people
that bad at healthcare
folks we got a lot of work to do i don't
need you to get me elected i need you
once i'm elected
i'll lead an effective strategy to
mobilize true
international pressure
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
she was more like a beauty queen
is
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
young around
[Music]
always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she
[Music]
who can stand when he's
just remember to always
[Music]
she told my baby
[Music]
young girl's heart
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
glass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
all right
[Music]
is yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
every night in my dreams
i see you i feel you
that is
the distance and spaces between
us you have come to
show you go
[Music]
wherever you are
i
[Music]
my heart will go on
[Music]
love can touch us one time
and last
[Music]
time and never
let go
love was when i loved you
one true time i know
in my life
[Music]
where you are
[Music]
[Music]
my heart will go
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
and i know
[Music]
foreign
go on
[Music]
[Music]
you are my fire
the one desire
believe when i
say i wanted
that way but we
[Music]
when you say that i
[Music]
tell me why
[Music]
you're one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
say
[Music]
[Music]
my fire the one
desire you are
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
[Applause]
that
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
somehow i think you got to stop down
[Music]
you really don't remember
wasn't something that he said
all the voices in your head
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
but you really don't remember
[Music]
is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
when you're married for the money
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
and you really don't remember
[Music]
is
don't have no answers
[Music]
i think they got the aliens
[Music]
is
[Music]
please please please
[Music]
please please
[Music]
wanna please
[Music]
you did me wrong
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
[Music]
gonna
[Music]
baby take my hand
[Music]
i wanna be a man
[Music]
i love your souls
[Music]
peace
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th
president of the united states donald
j trump
[Music]
[Applause]
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee across
the plains of texas from sea to shining
sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to l.a
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
where at least i know i'm free
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that life to me and i got this
end up next to you and defend her
still
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
god
[Music]
then i won't forget the men who died
who gave
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Applause]
well thank you very much and hello
kenosha it's nice to be back
it's nice to be back we spent a little
time with you a little law
and order we brought law and order to
kenosha all right
that's what we want and hello wisconsin
big day tomorrow big big day
big day and i think we're going to do
very well in wisconsin just like we did
four years ago
and it's an honor to be with you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and this is a lot of people this is a
lot of people
see you know what that means that means
we don't have to pay for the microphones
because they did a bad job
tomorrow we are going to win this state
and we are going to win
four more years in the white house
and with your vote we will continue to
cut your taxes
cut regulations support our police
support our great military protect your
second amendment that's under siege but
don't worry about
it unless sleepy joe got in then you can
forget about your second amendment
defend religious liberty and ensure more
products are proudly stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
usa
next year we will be and you know we're
going to be together next year
we're going to be together for four more
years and we're going to be together
forever because we're doing things that
nobody's
ever done and we're doing them together
and it was my pleasure to be with you a
number of months ago when
when you had you were in the news right
you were in the news
next year will be the greatest economic
year in the history of our country
and i hope you can hear can you hear
back there by the way
yes no hold it
[Music]
okay that was the problem you gotta get
the microphone
[Applause]
oh
what's wrong here how's that is that
getting better
[Applause]
and then we're supposed to pay these
people right uh
is that better come on
okay we'll do this
we'll have to improvise you know
sometimes
okay you're ready we'll have a cup which
is better this one
or this one
which one this one
is that better can you hear
this could be a very uncomfortable
evening for me
all right we'll figure it out come on
let's go
good job fellas i'm always saying i want
a perfect mic good job
unbelievable unbelievable is that better
now
so this is the first time i've ever used
a handheld for
an hour two hours three hours
now we have one more tonight after this
bend rapids
we finished up at grand rapids and uh
we finished up there four years ago and
a little bit superstitious let's
do it the same way we came here we came
to grand rapids
let's keep it going and i hope everyone
can hear me now yes
yeah all the way back there all the way
back
good you let me know you're not you're
not shy i was wondering everyone's going
i thought they didn't like me i was
saying
i'm not sure i said what's going on over
here right
good thank you very much so under my
leadership
our economy is now growing at the
fastest rate
ever recorded 33.1
fastest ever recorded we created a
record 11.4 million jobs in the last
five months that's a
record and while foreign nations are in
free fall we are creating an
economic powerhouse unrivaled anywhere
in the world
a recent gallup poll found that 56 of
americans
say they're better off today than they
were
four years ago that's
under the auspices of barack hussein
obama
and sleepy joe biden
you're not going to want to have joe
biden you know if we had to
see the media look at all the media back
there if we had if they had a cover
if they had to cover him for two months
and say
we have to bring the president back we
have to bring
we have to bring trump back they would
be out of business
they would be out of business if biden
harris and the radical left gain power
they will collapse our economy and send
your nation this wonderful nation
into a depression that was is what
you know they want this is the only guy
i've ever seen who runs by saying
we will he doesn't say it like that he
goes
we will raise your taxes i never heard
that before
you know i've covered politicians i've
been friends of politicians
i've been enemies also but i've never
seen somebody saying
we will raise your taxes they want to
give you the largest tax increase in the
history of our country and we can't let
that happen
we can't let that happen so get out and
vote tomorrow is the biggest
tomorrow will be i think will be the
most
important election in the history of our
country and i never thought i'd say that
i never thought i'd say it so get out
and vote
joe biden will raise your taxes four
trillion dollars
massively increase your regulations shut
down your farms
close down your factories how's he doing
so far
send your jobs overseas they start
booing them
i don't know is this guy really thinking
about i mean is
could he really win are we serious about
[Applause]
this
what the hell is going on is he serious
guy has no clue he's shot some people
are shot he's shot
did you see him today with the uh the
aviators right the glasses
right came on very tough he's very
agitated you know it's like
sort of like going crazy i think destroy
the suburbs dissolve your borders
terminate religious liberty
outlaw private healthcare confiscate
your gun second amendment is a deep
trouble
not with me it's not it hasn't you
notice it hasn't been touched right
it hasn't been touched you think that
was easy it wasn't easy
and indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lies
so i just signed an executive order to
teach our students pro-american values
pro-american values
biden has vowed to abolish the american
oil and natural gas
industries and ban fracking now
from your standpoint you don't like it
because you don't want energy costs
going up right
that's what he do biden's energy band
will send every state
into crushing poverty from wisconsin
to michigan nevada pennsylvania as long
as
i am president will remain the number
one producer of
oil and natural gas in the world and we
are right now
and we will remain energy independent
you know we're energy independent we
don't need foreign nations anymore
but we have good relationships in the
middle east you know where
we're doing peace in the middle east you
believe it no blood in the sand
peace in the middle east
joe biden is a globalist who spent 47
years
outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders and sacrificing american blood
and treasure
on foreign wars you know what they call
them the endless foreign wars countries
that
many of you have never heard about what
[Music]
what
[Music]
oh
i don't know i think we're doing fine
with this mic right i don't want to put
this guy under pressure
you're on stage you got 27 000 people
watching you don't get nervous
no he's not nervous he's a professional
i'll give you the name of his company
never use that company
nah he's fine don't worry about it this
is okay this isn't bad
do you want to oh you want to just put
it in there well that's
is it the same mic as the other one it's
a different mic
that means that one's supposed to be
better right that's not good
all right okay we'll take that sucker
out of there right congratulations
[Music]
how's he doing he's doing a good job
now we're back where we started
see the whole deal we're right back
where we started i think
okay okay
you know what and then i won't pay the
bill of the you know company that this
is crazy microphone and they'll do a
story trump is a
horrible human being he doesn't pay a
bill no
i don't like to pay bills when people do
a bad job you don't either but
i don't know they look like nice people
they come from kenosha so i'm going to
pay the bill anyway what the hell
you know well at least i proved one
thing you know did you ever see where i
lifted glass of water
and i wear the red tie they're sort of
expensive and you know you don't
like to spill water on the red tie right
so sometimes i'll use two hands and
because i want to catch the water
because i want to save the tie because
i'm basically cheap you know
so i'll take the water and i'll go like
this and i'll take a little zip
and they'll say there's something wrong
with him there's something
they're saying no i'm trying to save so
i go like this
so now by holding a mic all night long
like this you're gonna say well there's
nothing wrong with that right hand or
left hand
no did you ever hear that there's
something wrong you can't lift a glass
of water and i have no problem with that
someday i may like joe but i don't have
any problem
biden was a cheerleader for nafta and
china's entry into the world
trade organization wisconsin lost half
of
your manufacture think of it you lost
half
of your manufacturing jobs after the
betrayals these were betrayals by a lot
of people
and biden was one of them he's a corrupt
politician and he sold out
wisconsin to china but he's a corrupt
politician
and these people never told you that and
they don't want to write about it
and big tech doesn't want to talk about
it and it's off bounds
and they're not allowed to talk and we
have suppression
we have suppression this is a media
suppression
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
and if you take a look you've never seen
anything like it
the last famous last words right but but
no nobody's ever seen anything like it
you know his
son walks in his son had no job he left
the military
unfortunately it wasn't good and then
what happens is the father becomes vice
president
and this kid becomes like a human vacuum
cleaner
he follows the father into countries dad
who are you going to today well let's go
to china
and he's a vacuum cleaner follows the
father takes in money right it's
terrible
they give him one and a half billion
dollars one and a half billion
one and think of it one and a half
billion dollars
and he gets fees off that millions of
dollars a year
there's only one problem he has no
experience investing money
they give him the money they gave him
the money after 10 minutes i think our
congress has to take a look at that what
do you think fellas
i think you're gonna have to look at it
can you imagine you know i have a lot of
my kids
here tonight can you imagine if my kids
said yeah dad i got a billion and a half
dollars from china
oh i don't think they'd want to write
about that the fake news do you think
they'd write about that
then he gets three and a half million
dollars from
the mayor of moscow's wife right what
did he get that for
remember i asked that at the debate the
first debate i said it
chris wallace thought it was an
inappropriate question really i think
you think
chris wallace now i must tell you
i think kristen did a better job krista
welker right
and i don't mean she was perfect
actually some people said she wasn't
really very nice i thought she was nice
relatively speaking she was great for
what i get
how about the one savannah guthrie you
see that one that was
that was another beautiful live at nine
o'clock she's jumping out of a chair
she's like going crazy
but we all do well you know i don't get
questions like he gets
he gets sir uh what kind of ice cream
are you eating did you see that
they never asked me questions like that
in 2016
wisconsin voted to fire this carip
it and really it's like corrupt corrupt
political establishment right
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally
putting america first you're finally
putting america
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician right
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and nobody has
ever fought harder for you than i
am i will tell you nobody
when the violent mob came to kenosha
biden opposed
sending in the national guard of course
you remember this right
he did he didn't want to send in the
guard he thought it was
terrible to send in the gun and we sent
in the guard and we saved kenosha
are we saved i
said you know i think kenosha is going
to like me we did a good job
i wish they sent him in a little bit
earlier right if we hadn't been a little
bit earlier but that's okay
that's okay but we sent in and how
how good did the guard do though did we
do the job did they do the job
biden and kamala does anybody know who
kamala is that's
this wonderful woman she wants to be
your first
female president i don't think so i
don't think so
you know that's a good reason not to
vote for sleepy joe too right you don't
want to do that
you want to have we all want to see that
happen someday but we don't want this to
be the one right
but they're waging war on our police you
know that your police
we have a lot of police here tonight i
recognize it because
because i went and i met all of the
police i met a lot of great police
federal police i met the whole group
and you have great police
i agree with that but i stand with the
heroes of law enforcement and i was
honored to be endorsed by
kenosha county sheriff david beth thank
you david wherever you may be where's
david
thank you david that was so nice that
was so nice
they like you out there david that's
very good appreciate it david thank you
very much
and as i'm sure you've heard biden's far
left supporters
are threatening to loot and riot
tomorrow
if they don't get their way up there
i'll get their way are we all ready
david everybody ready oh
it's uh if they know we're ready and if
they know we're not playing games they
won't even be here they won't
show up you know it's like i brought an
old law
into existence when i saw them going
around all over the country
knocking down statues right and
monuments
and we signed we brought it in and i
signed it updated it signed it ten years
in prison have you knocked down a statue
or monument
and you don't see it anymore they look
and they say oh we'd like to knock that
one down but you know what ten years
is too much darling let's leave now
this is yet more evidence why the
radical left cannot be trusted with
power
we strongly condem political violence we
condem it and we condemn it strongly
biden must tell his supporters he
doesn't really have supporters
let's face it he doesn't have supporters
the guy's shot he doesn't have there's
there's an ideology that has supporters
and he's just a vessel you know he
happened to be the one that got through
because
elizabeth warren instead of getting out
like she should have
and letting bernie take it bernie i got
to tell you he
he is a great loser he really is he
loses
it happened with hillary and it happened
with uh elizabeth warren which he did
was incredible you know that's a similar
philosophy
but biden ended up being there biden
ended up being there and
that's the way it is that he has to tell
his supporters and i think you're going
to see something
look at the people over here they go oh
hello can you actually hear this
can you hear this
because this is the worst microphone
i've ever used in my life can you
actually hear me a little bit
they can in the back all the way back
that's good thank you
i can't believe it it sounds terrible to
me
his silence is it doesn't sound great
right to me it doesn't sound right
it's all right good you know what keep
saying it
that bill he says don't pay him don't
pay him
you hear that johnny don't pay the damn
bill will you please a piece of garbage
i gave
it's not even the first raid bike the
one the good one is
is it's put to rest we put it the rest
the good one we put the rest all right
don't pay him
but as president i will ensure peace
and order in this country we are going
to have peace and order
and you're going to have a day tomorrow
the likes of which i think people
haven't seen in a long time
a long you're going to have a redway
it's going to be a beautiful sight and
you know what we have a lot of we have
we actually have a country that outside
of a
radical group and this is a radical
group but we have a country that's very
well united when you look at a group of
people like this it's incredible
and i go from here i go i tell you grand
rapids
we have they say they have 40 50 000
people in grand rapids
last night in florida we had 45 000
people
no problem everybody's in love
everybody loves our country it's a
beautiful thing i'm telling you this
there's a lot of unity we just don't
complain you know we don't complain
we just go out and do what we have to do
but you know when we were having that
incredible run we were doing the best
and now we're almost at that same point
that we'll be there soon
but our country was uniting we were
getting calls
we had the best employment numbers ever
african-american asian-american
hispanic-american
and we were getting calls like yeah
maybe it's time we get together you know
because success brings people together
success
brings people together and you're going
to see that happening
because we're having numbers the likes
of which we've never had before
33 think of it 33.1 nobody's ever had
that
the highest was 1952 and it was less
than half of that number
so rioting looting an arson will be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law i'm just telling you that right now
i'm telling you that right now that if
people
are you know i hate to see where they
put boards up on a window this shouldn't
be that
it shouldn't be that but we are going we
are a country of law and order we have
to be we
are and people and you notice i hate to
say it
and but it's true this is a these are
democrat
mayors and governors these are
democrat-run cities and states
they're the ones if you look at new york
and chicago and
how about portland which is anarchist we
could solve that problem we tell the
governor
you want us to solve the problem we
solve it in 30 minutes
we solved it in seattle we went in we
were going to go in the morning we
announced we're going in in the morning
and they just raised their hands and
they left
the night before and we did a great job
in
you know minneapolis we did a great job
we're going to win minnesota for two
reasons we did a great job
now they could have called they could
have let us do it a week and a half
early that would have been nice you know
right so that the announcer remember the
anchor you looked over he says this is a
peaceful protest
thank you what a group what a group
what a group i've gotten to know this
state very well
you know you're surprised you know
you're the one that put us over the top
you know that right remember
we were waiting for pennsylvania four
years ago we're waiting for pennsylvania
they didn't want to call it oh they were
going crazy these people
they were crying they didn't know what
the hell was happening
they said this will be a very short
evening for donald trump
four years ago right and they were just
oh they were looking forward remember
the woman crying in the convention
center that beautiful
remember the woman he was going crazy
glasses
her head's gone she was she's i wonder
where she is right now she's
they put her away no no this was not a
person that i was
easily going to convince to be on my
side i think
she was going crazy but you remember at
the beginning they show everyone's happy
everyone's thrilled
they spent a fortune it was one of the
most beautiful
things i've ever seen in terms of a
stage they had it shaped like the united
states
hello back there are you okay
[Applause]
but that was a hell of an evening and
this evening is going to be
i'm telling you tomorrow it's going to
be
i can't say bigger there was was there
ever anything as big
i'll tell you the election is more
important but the evening will be
as good or almost as good and that's
okay too but that was the first
right that was the first that was some
evening
yeah that was some evening he won
florida
he won ohio he won it all
thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you very much
and because of the microphone we are
giving you back half of your admission
price
but considering that you paid nothing
i'm sorry you're getting nothing
the price is right nah it's fine
but you know but wasn't that something
though where they say uh
the evening begins and they say this is
going to be very quick
you know what happened they did exit
polls and a lot of the people said
none of your business oh who did you
vote for none of your business
that meant trump and they did 44 percent
you know that 44 of the people said none
of your business and that meant chop
they call it the none of your business
vote
but almost all of them i think maybe all
of them were trump
so they didn't count them so they said
oh this is going to be a blowout tonight
but they didn't realize you know these
pulses haven't been doing so good with
me and uh we blew it out it was
incredible it started with
ohio remember we're going to do great in
ohio tomorrow too by the way
great place
donald trump has won the state of ohio
that's a big sight
you know i heard for a year while we're
doing this you cannot win unless you win
the state of ohio
every night they did it and then all of
a sudden poll numbers started coming out
that i was leading in ohio
but anyway but they thought i was gonna
win by one point i won by eight
they said he won ohio he won by eight
points what the hell is going on here
that's a lot
and then they said oh no oh no please
don't tell me this
donald trump has won the state of
florida no no no no
no please please please
please remember martha raddatz abc oh my
god
please please don't tell me this oh no
i'm a neutral
i'm i'm very neutral i don't please
martial neutral please the tears swipe
them away quickly
no then we won florida then we won
georgia then we went south carolina then
we won the firewall was remembered in
north carolina
that's their firewall we are going to
win north carolina they have they put so
much money into north carolina
but uh we had an asset from north
carolina named
lara lara lara trump
married to married to the legendary eric
trump where are you are you two there
we had a we had a big asset there laura
trump and
she knew that area so well and they
loved her so much
[Music]
they loved her so much and they just had
another
baby and they named the baby carolina
they named the baby carolina
and i i tell you though but i i said we
have to give south carolina some
credit too for that
bring them up come on up get over here
come on
bring them up break them up
great come on come on laura
this one they love her in
north carolina south carolina
pennsylvania
and they love her in wisconsin too here
you go
i'm done now apparently wisconsin
who here is ready for four more years
a vote for donald trump is a vote for
freedom
a vote for donald trump is a voice vote
for the future
a vote for donald trump is a vote for
god
and a vote for donald trump is a vote
for
america
how do you guys feel are we going to win
wisconsin
let's go do this a second time thank you
great job thank you very much thank you
honey
thanks eric thanks sweetheart
they're doing a good job they're working
hard i'll tell you they're all working
hard
they're all working hard we have a whole
group of families like a family reunion
today
now well you know this is now the big
time because tomorrow's the big day
and uh we have one more stop see
actually you know i did five today but
i could say i could say i did six
because
in miami we finished it close to two
o'clock in the morning
so let's say i did six today okay after
grand rapids
biden is bought and paid for by big tech
big media and powerful special interests
you know that
they own him they control him and they
know he will always do their bidding
and when he raises 300 million dollars
for this campaign
in a short period of time ask him what
deals did you have to make because i
would be the greatest fundraiser of all
time
i can call the wall street guys i know
them all i could say
send me 25 million dollars immediately
please yes sir mr president
i will but you know once you do that
you're totally compromised you can't do
anything properly
once you do that and i say i don't want
to do that
and we we did very well with the
fundraising stuff but a lot of it came
in small donations
first time a republican has ever raised
a lot of money with small donations like
61 average or something like that
every corrupt force in american life has
betrayed you
and hurt you and they're all supported
by
joe biden the failed establishment that
started the disastrous
foreign wars they're supported by sleepy
joe biden the career politicians that
offshored your industries
and you had plenty offshore and
decimated your factories
they support joe biden the open borders
lobbyists all the people that killed our
fellow citizens with
illegal drugs gangs and crime and you
know a lot about that
they support joe biden the anti-american
radicals defaming our noble history
heritage
and heroes they support joebite and
that's cancel culture we don't believe
in cancer culture do we
antifa and the rioters and looters and
marxists and left-wing extremists
they all support joe biden
this election comes down to a simple
choice
do you want to be ruled by the corrupt
and selfish political class
or do you want to be governed by the
american people it's what it's all about
it's the american people
they've taken that away they've taken it
away
and what's going on with big tech and
what's going on with the media
is nobody has ever seen anything like it
there's never been anything like it
nobody has seen anything like it
where you know you can't have a side you
can't have
you can't have a scandal if there's
nothing written about it it's pretty
though
a vote for biden is a vote to give
control of government over to the
globalists and communists and socialists
and
wealthy liberal hypocrites
hypocrites who want to silence censor
cancel and punish you these are
real real trouble if you want your
children to be safe if you want your
values to be respected if you want your
if you want to be just treated with
dignity and respect
then i am asking you tomorrow to go out
and vote for your all-time favorite
president
because we still have work to do
remember what i said four years ago i
am your voice and we will all together
make america great again that's what
we're doing it's what we've done
for the last four years the depraved
swamp has tried everything to stop me
can you imagine if they didn't do the
hoax the russia russia hoax right russia
russia russia
how about shift getting up the other day
the laptop from hell
right that's where's hunter where's
hante
where's hunter oh he's in a country i
say his father just left
the country he's gonna scam them for a
couple of bucks where is hunter
no but he's got the laptop from hell
and schiff got up with the watermelon
head right like a watermelon and he goes
this was produced by russia
these people are crazy i tell you
what a crazy bunch but they know
i don't answer to them i answer to you
it's true i'd look i didn't need this
i didn't need this i had a very nice
life
i had a very nice life but you know what
it's the greatest thing i ever did
because
no administration no president in the
first three and a half years
the biggest tax cut in history the
biggest regulation
cuts rebuilding our military
look at what we've done look at what
we've done our vets just gave a 91
approval rating the highest in history
the highest in history now look at what
we've done space force i never even
talked about space force
i never talked i i realized we needed it
after i was in office i looked i saw
i saw russia i saw china i said we need
space force
first time in 74 years new one right a
new one right congressman
we did uh we did a great job on it
together we will defeat the corrupt
establishment we will dethrone the
failed
political class we will drain the
washington swamp
and we will save the american
dream a dream for your children your
grandchildren right
a dream for your children and your
grandchildren
we have the energy in the people to
prove the corrupt
media wrong and that's what we have we
have an energy like no
movement has ever had in this country
[Music]
[Applause]
you know uh somebody would go in and do
well in new hampshire as an example i'm
thinking about one minute because i have
a lot of respect for him
he did well came in second in a primary
and he became famous for many years what
we did is we won all the primaries we
won
everything and then we won the
presidency no there's never been a
movement like this
and now they go after us illegally
they spied on our campaign our campaign
is not mice
our campaign they tried to
take out a duly elected president of the
united states and we caught them
and we caught them and let's see what
happens to them
and you know who is a part of it barack
hussein obama
and sleepy joe biden
and plenty of others like comey etc but
plenty of others but they were a part of
it
so now we'll see what happens right
we're going to see
we're going to see what happens so but
you have to get out and vote
this is the biggest thing get out and
vote who by the way who's already voted
all right but we have a tendency to vote
on election day of republicans so
let me ask you who is planning to vote
tomorrow
[Applause]
very important very important is anybody
planning to vote for
sleepy joe biden please raise your hand
does anybody have the courage to raise
you
all right yeah get out and vote well
that's good that's a lot of people so a
lot of you vote a little bit early then
do you trust the ballot system do you do
early voting or do you do the ballot
early i like early but early is good
early is good ballot is not good we got
a very
horrible horrible ruling from the
supreme court of the united states
a ruling that puts our country in danger
actually
on pennsylvania they have so much time
to do this thing oh
let them put their votes in and give
them plenty of time
you know we have a date it's called
november 3rd we don't have a date that
says
many days later we don't have a date
that says you're allowed to
go and start you know putting your vote
in later and we can tabulate it later
take your time
the whole world is waiting to find out
and there's great danger in that number
one there's danger that
there's a lot of shenanigans that go on
from that time forth there's a lot of
shenanigans
and then there's a lot of bad things
that can happen with
with the streets i mean you're going to
have a population
that's going to be very very angry and
you just can't do that
that is such a dangerous decision that
is such a disappointment when i heard
that decision
that's a terrible decision just you go
take a look at it and i know you people
are taking a look at it
but there's not a decision that i've
ever heard of like that
where people if you want to put your
ballot in and if you want to
you go and you put it in two or three or
four weeks early
you don't go and but yeah he said you
had a whole year you had a lot of time
you had a lot of time so they say oh
this is so terrible you know
they gave them extra time and then all
the time so now that we're going to be
all waiting around because pennsylvania
we're going to win pennsylvania it's a
great
stay but you know it shouldn't like you
it's in a total shutdown they shut it
down the governor is a democrat he shut
it down
it'll probably open on the fourth it'll
open
he'll announce ladies and gentlemen now
that the election's over we're going to
open it up right
but you can't do that that's a very very
dangerous decision by the supreme court
i guess it was a political decision i
don't know what it was
i don't know what they were thinking and
you know what maybe
i should maybe i shouldn't be speaking
this way i'm very disappointed on behalf
of this country that a thing like this
could happen
because we could be waiting for weeks
before we ever find out
what's going on the whole world is
waiting for this decision
it's a very sad it's a very sad thing
and hopefully it's going to be changed
hopefully their wisdom and they have
wisdom
hopefully their wisdom will prevail and
they'll do something and
lawyers will be going in and they'll be
fighting and you know but
people in fact it's all over television
tonight i'm coming from place to place
and i'm
the good thing about air force one it's
got more televisions and
any hotel room in the world okay you
have them on the floors you have them on
the ceilings
you have them all over and you see the
the comments that are being made about
the decision and
some of the pros are saying this is a
very dangerous decision for our country
because so many things i mean they're
going to say well how many votes short
are we
we need 6 000 votes well let's take 6
000 of these
we'll put them over here let's take six
thousand of these
it's gonna be cheating it's going to be
cheating it's like
they're putting these people and you
know what we don't consider the people
that have been running elections in
philadelphia to be very honest we've had
a lot of problems with philadelphia
so that's the story and hopefully
that'll be changed and
i'm sure the people would say oh you
shouldn't speak that way about the
supreme court
we've had so many bad decisions out of
the supreme court that i will speak that
way and that's the way it is this
election
is also a choice between a deadly biden
lockdown
and a safe vaccine that ends and by the
way we're rounding the turn anyway but
we have great
vaccines we have great vaccines coming
we have great vaccines coming and it's a
lot of good things
are happening and you know when you look
at the therapeutics excuse me
i'm right here no i don't think the
therapeutic
helped me i don't think i needed it i'm
glad i got it right regeneron we're
going to make it available free
to anybody that needs it we're making it
available free to anybody that needs it
free but i'll tell you what i i'm sure i
didn't because i'm
you know i'm a perfect physical specimen
and i am considered very very young i'm
considered young for my age
no i'm a perfect specimen i'm in perfect
shape
so i'm sure i would have thrown it away
but uh
no but i had it and the next morning i
was not feeling good at all i tell you
the doctor said sir i hate to say it
you've just tested positive i said
doc sean a great doctor
white house doctor i said sean tell me
what does that mean test it positive for
what
sir you've tested positive for the
china plague he used it much nicer than
he said covent
he said coleman you know it's got about
37 names you know that we can name it
i always like to have a china in there
because i like to be accurate
but buddy said sir you've tested
positive for coma i said i'm in the
middle of the campaign i can't be
positive for covert
and uh so anyway so i was and i didn't
feel too good and
the first lady had it at least now you
know that all those rumors is that she
lives in virginia
separate i mean at least now you know
she lives in the white house
because she got it probably for me or
whatever i don't know what the hell
you know do you ever hear the first lady
lives in virginia in a beautiful house
over a river or something
no no she lives here but at least that
and then
i know people love the first lady they
love them
[Applause]
they love the first lady it's true they
love her she's doing a good job
they love that whole family back there
they love that family back there
great family hi tiffany
so so then so melania has it but she
knocked it out
pretty good and i i did a great job you
know i was surrounded by these doctors
12 doctors have told the story each one
was a specialist
johns hopkins walter reed medical center
is incredible you know that's our
military center it's incredible
and i'm surrounded right i'm just
surrounded by these brilliant doctors
one thing when you're president you get
a lot of doctors and each doctor grabbed
a different part of my body
and i said i don't like this at all but
they told me about this one thing and i
said i really do i like it i really but
it was
very you know a little bit early what
we've done with getting it through the
fda has been incredible biden wouldn't
have this stuff done for
years but we had his chance with the
swine flu and totally blew it right
it was a disaster it was a disaster
anyway
so i wake up the next morning and i'm
telling you i felt like superman
i was so i wanted to get out i said give
me another trade deal to renegotiate
that these
clowns have screwed up give me a trade
deal to renegotiate and where am i
supposed to be well sir
could you take it easy for a couple of
days and people are sort of amazed i've
done these things i mean i do them these
are
not easy to do especially when you have
no damn microphone i mean
i'm working harder on this one than i
have on all six that i did today
this is the hardest one
because i have a microphone that was
obviously meant for congressmen and
senators
not for a president so it's a little bit
off
but that's okay you know you have to
learn how to imp isn't that funny when
you put it back in here and hand it to
me
but that's the way we started i thought
that was better nobody got that only
this front row got that one
i thought that was very clever actually
but then he came up to me the doctor
sean he said sir
i'm sorry to inform you that your son
baron has tested positive
again i said brilliantly for what
he said for covet i said oh that's
terrible
oh no he'll be okay sir he'll be okay i
said it's terrible
but he's young and he's strong and he's
very tall have you ever seen i say
hi barrett 14 years old he's very tall
he's he's definitely tall and he's
strong but he's young
and i said that's terrible he said no
he'll be okay sir he'll be okay
and i said well i hope like 12 minutes
later i say how's baron doing doctor
sarah he's 100 now he's
get your kids back to school okay
right get them back to school
yeah all right so we're going to mass
distribute the vaccine in just a few
short weeks it's going to be coming out
very soon and we will quickly eradicate
the virus
wipe out the china plague once and for
all get it the hell out of here
we will never forget either we will not
forget that was not good you know we
made a great trade deal with china as
you know very well
but you know the ink wasn't dry before
we got this and
no good no good joe biden is promising
to delay the vaccine
and turn america into a prison state
locking you in your home
while your your far left anarchists are
allowed to roam the streets burn down
your cities
hit people over the head they're allowed
to do that
that's why i always call all of these
rallies protests these are not rallies
anymore
because you're allowed to have a protest
you can't have a rally and you can't go
to church
you know you're not allowed to go to
church but you're allowed to burn down
the cities with a protest so
we always call these friendly protests
the biden lockdown will mean no school
no graduations no weddings no
thanksgiving
no christmas no easter no 4th of july
and no future other than that
it's really not a bad way to go
a vote for sleepy joe biden is a vote
for lockdowns layoffs
misery and no fracking how about the guy
no fracking for
over a year and a half there will be no
fracking he goes to pennsylvania
absolutely will frack okay and these
guys don't do anything about it if you
want a vaccine to kill the virus
a job to support your family and freedom
to live your life
then you have no choice but to cast your
ballot
for a gentleman named donald j trump
and as i said and you have to remember
this you know because during the debate
the
debate was good thank you thank you very
much
thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you everybody it's a great honor
to be with you i really did during the
kenosha
disaster i really got to be friendly
with a lot of people up here long before
that because
we've had so many different people that
we deal with you have
great people we're going to introduce
you a few of them but you have great
people here but
i really got to know you during that
problem that potential crisis that we
put out
very very swiftly once we got called and
uh
it's great you're great people you built
the country you're great people joe
biden
and as i said he ran the uh h1n1 he
called it n1h1 he couldn't get it right
he still does he can't get it right i
said joe h comes before n it's easy to
remember
h1n1 swine flu and he failed horribly
and he was a laughing stock all over
washington as you remember and his chief
of staff
i don't know why this guy said it but he
made the worst statements he said this
guy
we have no idea what we're doing now all
of a sudden he's coming and he's
he was the one that said i i shouldn't
close it down
to china heavily infected china right
you remember that mess
anyway then now he runs he said i should
have closed it sooner
it's uh it's really disgraceful
secretary of defense
robert gates a respected man he said
biden has been wrong on nearly every
major foreign policy and national
security issue
over the past four years right
four years he said he's always wrong and
he has been always wrong
i don't believe he's even running i
can't believe the whole thing
i've watched i watched the debates you
had 27 total killers on the stage and he
was there and
but you don't have to believe me because
it's you
and because it's wisconsin we spent a
fortune and hopefully that'll work
better than the microphone
try it put it on
joe biden joe biden
[Music]
how do you take it this was today you
forgot the show i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test come on
man that's like saying you before you
got in this program you're taking a test
where you're taking cocaine or not what
do you think huh
are you a joke by the way it's my little
sister valerie and i'm jill's husband
oh no oh you switched on me this is my
wife this is my sister
they switched on me by telling if you
have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black there is not a
single solitary reason in the world
why why as i said we shouldn't be in a
position
that everybody that's my wife jill hey
jilly i'm jill's husband actually
and cornpop was a bad dude and he
ran a bunch of bad boys and i did yeah
he
and back in those days the shot things
have changed play the radio make sure
the television
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night
the the phone make sure the kids hear
words
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created
by the go you know the you know the
thing because if you could
take care if you were a quartermaster
you can
sure in health take care of running a
you know department store
uh thing you know where in the second
floor of the ladies department or
whatever you know what i mean alive sick
and tired of smart guys
you know the rapidly rising uh um
uh in with uh
with uh i don't know uh uh
mendo caucus no you haven't you're a
lion dog-faced pony soldier
you're getting nervous man what kind of
country we're going to be
four more years of george georgia
he is going to find ourselves in a
position where
if trump gets elected uh we're going to
be we're going to be in a different
world
after lie after lie after live
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate
and by the way you know i should
understand and it gets hot i got a lot
of i got hairy legs
that turn that that that that that turn
uh blonde in the sun and the kids used
to come up and reach into the pool
and rub my leg down so it was trained
and then watched the hair
come back up again they'd look at it so
i learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my
lap and i've loved kids jumping on my
lap
rock and i think it's a right for people
who have bad at
care we have to do at least several
things one
we have to depend on what the president
president's going to do right now
and first of all he has to tell
wait till the cases before anything
happens look
exacerbating the need for example firms
up environmental justice sorry as a bug
folks we got a lot of work to do i don't
need you to get me elected the case we
cannot let
this we've never allowed any crisis from
the civil war straight through to
the pandemic of 17 all the way around 16
we have never
never let our democracy say
second fiddle way that we can both have
a democracy and elections and at the
same time
correct the public health everywhere
i've been hearing all around the country
you're trying your best but it never
feels like enough
thanks and here comes the train that he
tried to
make sure didn't continue to run
no that's the commuter all right
but folks look anyway i am uh
i am very willing to let the american
public
judge my physical mental filth my
physical as well as my mental
fitness i'll need an effective strategy
to mobilize
true international pressure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you what a good job
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much
that was just a small little sampling we
had many more
some were too rough to put on we just
decided
but that said look this is not what our
country needs this isn't
this isn't about yeah it is about me i
guess when you think about it
but but this is not what our country can
have we can't have this
one thing i'll tell you i learned
president xi
of china president putin of russia
kim jong-un of north korea and many
others all of them
they're very sharp they're very smart
they're very sharp
he wasn't show up 25 years ago and now
it's not you can't let this happen to
our country that's all i can say
because it's not a game we're not
playing a game you know we have a good
time tonight we love each other we're
having fun but
when you get right there it's not about
fun we can't let this happen to our
country
joining us tonight speaking about
somebody that's great
is a senator who is my friend
he's my friend and he is a he just
doesn't stop
he's one of the sharpest toughest people
in washington
and he is on when he's on somebody that
person has no chance or that
bad group has no chance he's the head of
homeland
but he's a respected person and he's
your senator and we love him
and i'm telling you everybody in
washington talks about him in the
greatest of tones
senator ron johnson ron thank you
[Applause]
and he doesn't stop you talk about not
giving up
he doesn't stop and we have
brian style congressman great job great
job you're doing
thank you thank you very great job
you're doing
glenn grothman glenn thank you very much
great job glenn's doing a great job
darren lahood
baron good job darren what a good group
and you have a wonderful candidate who's
going to be
running and you know who that is he's
where is he where is jim jim jim
oberweis jim thank you jim
and i heard you're doing well glenn
how's he doing in the polls okay
he said he's going to win when he says
he's going to win he's going to win too
good
and i heard you're doing very well good
very good state gop
chair andrew hitt how we doing andrew
tomorrow good we're okay
because he's doing a nice job but if we
don't win he'll be fired immediately
and a friend of mine and a guy who's
done a terrific job he loves this state
kenosha's own reince priebus
where is he right stand up rights
where's rights
what a nice what a good guy he is too
what a good guy
he's done took me years to learn how to
pronounce his name properly
but he's a fantastic person i'm
especially glad to be joined tonight
by don jr and kimberly and
[Applause]
don
come on up they're safe bring them up
come on come on up see he's uh
he's a mountain man he loves to go out
the hunting he doesn't you don't have a
jacket
if you catch a call he likes the
outdoors huh
you doing okay come on say something
hello wisconsin
[Applause]
or if i was joe biden i'd say florida
but you know
doesn't matter you don't have to be
right but thank you guys
thank you for the support we've been
seeing it on the ground
every day for weeks because unlike the
bidens we don't have
a mainstream media that will campaign
for us we have to do it ourselves
on the ground with you guys
so we need you to get out and bring your
friends to vote
tomorrow and when we do we can not only
keep making america great again
but we can make liberals cry again
get out there and do it wisconsin get
out there and do it
thank you guys
job thank you thanks kim thank you
sweetie
thank you very much
and i'll tell you they're campaigning
hard they're all campaigning hard
they're all campaigning so i see back
there
ivanka and jared jarrett is doing peace
in the middle east
jared is doing a great job peace in the
middle east
jared are you going to get it done
you're gonna get it done jared i hope so
come on up come on up jared and ivanka
come on
come on this is like an old home week
for you
here we are i look back the whole family
is here
tiffany come on up i see tiffany come on
up tiffany
come on up here honey say something
hello wisconsin
you have heard my father talk about
some of the things that he's been able
to accomplish over the past four years
and i am so proud of so many of them but
i will say
the thing that i am most proud of
is unlike politicians he's never
forgot why he ran for president and who
he is fighting for
you never forgot
it is a beautiful thing to see and he
works
so so hard every single day and let me
just tell you
washington has not changed donald trump
donald trump has changed washington
it's true it's true and there's more to
come
so now we have to fight for him and we
have to fight for this country
that we love so much and get out and
vote tomorrow
thank you wisconsin we love you and god
bless
thank you sweetheart jared would you
like to say something about peace in the
middle east
to this very small crowd
it's really an honor to be with all of
you i was just say in
washington if the things that the
politicians were talking about
were easy they would have been done a
long time ago but it took a leader like
president trump to come in
and shake things up a little bit but
we've seen things get done that we never
imagined could happen
and i can tell you the table is set
there are so many more things to do
and this whole family loves america we
love this country we love all of you
and we will never stop fighting to get
all the things done that president trump
has promised so
thank you for your support thank you for
your love
[Applause]
thank you
thank you great job jared thank you
thank you everybody
thanks kids
thanks everybody and i see some people
do i see corey lewandowski back there
yes do i see david is that david
come on get over here corey corey
lewandowski
david come on david bossie what what a
group
stand up just there we don't have to
hear from them the mic doesn't work
anyway so don't worry about it
great job great job good luck on
television tomorrow
i think you're going to have a blowout
tomorrow okay
but i want to thank look i have a great
family i have a family they're working
all the time all of them and
we appreciate it special people and
we're really you know we didn't need
this we had a wonderful
super it was just going good then i said
you know maybe i'll give it a shot you
know why because of trade it started
because of trade i hate it
i watched it was so obvious the way we
were being ripped off on trade
and i said let's give it a whirl and i
said to my wife i'd like to do it what
do you think she said well you have to
really want it
because you know you will win don't you
i said do you think so really
she had more uh she had a little more
security in the fact that if i ran no
she said you will win
if you but you have to make sure you
want it i said i want to do it because
we have so many things we could do i
never thought we would have done what
we've done though we've done
a lot together together we've done so
much i mean you think about all
it probably started more i talked to ron
about it probably started with trade
though because
i hated our companies were leaving to
mexico canada
china they were all leaving our country
we had these stupid laws and
horrible tax deals where they had
incentives to move to mexico they got
incentivized to move to mexico
somebody had a concept gee let's make
mexico great again you know i said no
i want to make our country great again
so that's the story it's a complicated
story but
it all evolved into this evening and
tomorrow we have our big day
and tomorrow i think that uh i think
it's gonna be a really special day and i
hope you can all go out
you'll find the time and go out and vote
and we're gonna make you very proud
you're gonna make
you're gonna be made really very proud i
just finished you off for decades our
politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations fighting foreign wars and
defending foreign borders but now we're
finally protecting our nation rebuilding
our cities and we are bringing
our jobs and our factories and our
troops finally finally finally we're
bringing them back home to the usa where
they belong
for 47 years joe biden viciously
attacked
black americans he called young black
men super predators all the time
to every black american i am asking you
to go out tomorrow and vote it's very
important
this is your one and only chance to show
sleepy joe biden what you think of his
decision to attack you
to jail you and to betray you i'm
fighting for you
and we got criminal justice reform
completed
prison reform completed opportunity
zones completed with the great
tim scott of south carolina and funding
for historically black
colleges and universities we got that
done
and i say all the time and sometimes
people say that's a big statement then
they realize it's true
with the exception of abraham lincoln
there's never been a
president that has done so much for the
black
community and it's my honor it's my
honor
[Music]
it is my honor and under my leadership
and by the way i don't know if you've
been watching what's going on in florida
we're doing really well
and you know what they're talking about
the black community
and the hispanic american community is
really
they're liking trump what's going on now
we're doing very well
florida florida is doing very well
so in conclusion over the next four
years
we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
it's already begun we will hire more
police increased penalties for assaults
on law enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
with god's help we will defend the right
to life
religious liberty free speech
and the right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
which is totally under siege but as long
as
ron johnson and your great congressman
are there we will protect it right glenn
everybody
we will protect it ron that's an easy
one for us but it wouldn't be easy if he
got it we wouldn't have
enough to say about it we will maintain
america's unrivaled military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require price
transparency starts on january 1st and
it will be bigger than health care
lower drug prices even more favored
nations the drug companies do not like
me too much i will tell you we'll have
the lowest drug prices anywhere in the
world
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and we will restore patriotic education
to our schools
[Music]
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized to america
we had as this i mean we have had i
watched
obama go out and apologize all over the
world
he would apologize all over the world he
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america and standing up
for the great great people of wisconsin
tomorrow you have the power you have the
vote you have
the power really to save america we
can't go down that path
we will never be a socialist
country
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers grab
your boss by the tie and say come on
boss
we got to get out and vote get out and
vote from madison
to milwaukee from janesville to lacrosse
and from your team is doing well right
your team is doing well green bay green
bridge
do you like you like your quarterback i
do i like your quarterback
you know who i like we like brett favre
do you like bradford
[Applause]
you know that brett favre endorsed me
last week right
we love brett favre what a great guy i
got to know him he's a
he's a tough cookie he's a tough guy
great great guy
green bay to right here in kenosha we
inherit the legacy of american patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears
to defend our country and to defend our
freedom
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes
who crossed the oceans settled the
continent
tamed the wilderness laid down the
railroads
raised up the great skyscrapers won
two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america into the single
greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet to come
[Music]
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power to you
the american people with your help
your devotion and your drive we are
going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning
winning you we are one movement
one people one family and one glorious
nation
under god and together with the
incredible people of wisconsin
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again your
401ks are doing very well
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again we're
proud again we're respected
we're respected again we have made
america
safe again and we
will make america great again
thank you wisconsin thank you wisconsin
go out and vote thank you it's a great
[Music]
honor
[Music]
you